takes a lot of minds to make this thing
work as well as hagakure don't know hi
sir
you know yeah you see he knows Gary
doesn't know you her name Queen that is
the name of a musical group yes lead
singers long since passed away I know
he's incredible he was great wasn't he
he was really one of the one of the most
notable musical performances from a
singer I've ever seen it's when Freddie
Mercury had on a tuxedo toward the end
of his tour in life and he come on in
and join us
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is here wait wait
wait no your key keep going I wanted to
introduce nothing yeah I Polly he just
interrupted Gary and Jeffrey can't
refuse me just fine Jerry I rushed over
deep or you know like we give it back to
get for it will you give it back to like
yeah you sound like I was helpful no
yeah is me anyway what I'm saying was
Freddie Mercury did a performance of a
song called the great Pretender right uh
various areas offer the mic back make
friends again this is it's not it's not
a band well nobody's not French here
good if you think that you need to see
dr. Phil dr. Phil yeah he's good that
guy yeah yeah look you know he would
help you with your clothing design sit
why would I need Jeffrey Dean Morgan is
here and I'm excited on the biggest
show-and-tell
yeah not only on the biggest show on
television but he's arguably the biggest
character on the biggest show on
television what is the biggest show on
television uh walking to show the
referring to as The Walking Dead have
you heard of The Walking Dead Gary uh
it's huge it's you gotta you gotta you
gotta keep up with what's going on
looking damn Walking Dead is a massive
show and I have been to the other side
twice right there's no such thing as
death in fact I'll take the letters you
spelled death right and create a
definition for because I've been the
other side twice death the EA th stance
or don't expect a tragedy here maybe I
think that's the I think we could read
in the show yeah you know the problem is
I expect a tragedy here I feel like no
there's no problem just a problem is an
opportunity in the sky and that's the
other jeopardy morning's all right right
now Jeffery is thinking of can't
understand negan time definition shows
this quick brilliant author where did
you grow up I grew up in Seattle oh I
love that place yeah it's a great time
oh man it's lovely and where about you
weren't where did you grow up I was born
in Goose Creek Texas 11:50 a.m. June
29th 1944 Goose Creek is now bait town
it's down 30 miles east of Houston it's
all black Doug Bay no no no man you
whack and next to the Houston Ship
Channel can I just say that Buddy Holly
was one of my favorite performances ever
by any human being thank you yeah it's
incredible absolutely brilliant
nursey carnie that's another one of my
favorite laughs I feel like I was chosen
by Buddy spirit to play him yeah when I
sang I realized months after the movie I
was channeling his voice his spirit
makes him believe that you were mad I
was ya know I didn't know what time
every every scene in that movie was one
take bad no kidding yeah it was an
amazing performance you Jimmy do you
prefer playing a real person like that
like a Buddy Holly or somebody that you
can there's all this tape and you can
base the performance on I think there's
a lot more pressure to play a real
person if you think about it that way
but I thought when they gave me the
permanent and dyed my hair black and
gave me those clothes I couldn't find
Gary Busey in the mirror yeah
hello and well that'll be the day would
you say goodbye and it wasn't me saying
his buddy
cuz I was playing the part of buddy in
fact buddy was playing the part of me
right
that's [ __ ] heavy yeah it's pretty
happy especially this early right yeah
well there's so many reference points to
say if you get it right or if you get it
wrong so there's a lot I think there's a
lot of pressure and you could say the
same thing you know about the negan
character guys this is a
character that like people who are
familiar with the Walking Dead comics
and there's a lot of them we're so
excited about coming to the show
the you've got a lot on your shoulders
sure I guess to a certain extent um
although you know I'm playing a
character that was created five years
ago in the mind of Robert Kirkman so
it's probably a little bit different
than going you know I can show everybody
how he's but you know yeah have you ever
been dead I've ever been dead in in a
real life makes me put that together no
I haven't uh uh but I know you you were
in a really bad accident right yeah it
was an accident it turned into a
blessing because out of that accident I
created the traumatic brain injury Act
that President Clinton signed into an
act in 1997 Gary's being a little
braggadocious cuz he's been dead and he
wanted to you know no no no it is a
little braggadocious to point out well
you know he hasn't been dead
braggadocious yeah down in Louisiana and
I I didn't know there I didn't know and
there's no such thing as death you go to
the other place with a guy a guide and
it's very very fun so is that a trick
question when you asked him nothing's a
trick with me okay obvious one help me
out here speak no no I I'm listening
here you have the floor what do you
shoot the show we shoot outside of
Atlanta Georgia oh yeah um so it's very
hot we shoot all summer long and well
welcome to humidity Vale exactly right
oh did you guys just finish you just had
just just wrapped season seven um so I
was there from what end of April until
Thanksgiving are you happy about how the
show ends this season uh yeah I I think
that the audience will bow I mean I
don't happy is a kind of a it depends on
what side of things you're looking at it
but as a fan of the show I think we
ended this season there's everybody
ended up dead
pardon me does everybody end up dead at
the end of the table no a lot of people
do
it's the walking dead is takes place in
the I guess the zombie apocalypse yeah
and they get it's like a different kind
of carnival yeah yeah yeah yeah and and
negan is a pretty amazing character
we've been watching this people travel
for years now throughout this
apocalyptic world and kind of looking up
to him when one guy's become the hero
Rick and and we've been watching this
all build and build and build and
finally he's met this force negan who's
got all these guys behind him that are
how was negan no I didn't even is this
the force of nature he you know eat I
guess the heroes of the show the show's
been on for six seasons before negan
this character shows up and it follows
this group of survivors led by one guy
and they've become our heroes of the
show
divers dead people walking no no there's
dead people walking that they fight off
there are human live humans and I guess
I guess what you find out in the course
of this show and this year especially is
the problem isn't the walking dead it's
the it's the living and in this case
it's it's negan who's with it it's like
when you break it all down the bottom
line its executives it is at AMC I'm
kidding how much pressures to walk into
a show that that's it's all you the
biggest show on television right now
it's definitely the biggest show on
cable and it's like you have a major
role in it so it's like you know yeah if
you [ __ ] it up everyone you know just
thought I think I feel it more now I
didn't you know I was a fan of the show
but I don't think I realize just how
many people watched it or how people
were so passionate about it and all that
stuff that goes with it until you live
it I mean it's just like yeah it's a
different world now you know it's it's
what networking on it's on AMC um
American movie channel is that what it
is well I won classics yeah I think I
think was I don't know what I mean now I
think it's just am say it's just yeah it
used to be yeah something else movie
classics but I don't think it is that
any Turner Clinic movies right now it's
not on that channel it's on AMC but what
I hope what I didn't say it was on that
channel
I know I know just make sure the
audience knows it was it's a nd gate
thank you use American movie class
American movie classic yeah yeah dolly
shot I was wrong
mm oh you're never wrong thank you
nobody's ever wrong right you're wrong
you're failing yourself here's what I
picked up especially it hit me when I
was watching the premiere it's like a
walking bumper sticker okay yeah
everything that comes out your mouth I
feel like it could be like you know
waiting I like it I know I got a bumper
sticker for you go there's gonna be your
favorite what it's called
I'd rather be drooling why cause he's
dead this character is still dying but
but what I picked up watch that's pretty
good is very good really good pull up
behind you see that and go whoo steer
clear this dude yeah that way you'll be
isolated you say I think a lot of guests
for this show actually leave with that
bumper say um what I picked up from the
season premiere mmm was that difficult
it's got to be to be this guy because
like negan Lake is so cool you know and
it's so like quake and has all the
one-liners in excess a look that you go
of it you want to look you want to love
him right the instinct is for him to be
that bad guy that you love right but
you've got to make choices and I guess
the writers have to make choices too
what are you doing Gary good that's not
me
I'm pretty sure it was then make it so
that he still hated right and I think he
does things that you're gonna hate on me
when he's bashing someone's brains in oh
that would be a hater yeah yeah Nellie's
incorrect actually on it is a beloved
character for seven years right doesn't
Gary panting is throwing me off yeah
it's not panning it's excitement oh I'm
doing a play called the perfect crime
I'm playing the park baseball bat killer
shut up laughing whoa oh sweet baseball
bat killer
yeah that sounds familiar well you are
you are you being serious yeah oh I'm a
baseball bat killer and walking dead are
you kidding me I'm not [ __ ] with you
do you have
you know if I went it's an excellent
seal it's about it's a name's Lucy a
seal wrapped in barbed wire a baseball
bat wrapped in barbed wire and why you
picked the name Lucille it was the name
of negan's wife who dies of cancer and
he's still Lucille caring you know
wrapped in barbed wire wrapped in barbed
wire you want to take that idea run with
it in your play above y'all make it
happen tomorrow that's kind of a topical
qi on the oracle or come out with
audience with luck I'll come out right
with a bad wrapped in barbed wire and
tell the audience if you're not reacting
to this play properly you're gonna meet
my bat the hard way I like that I like
that sounds right out of negan's plays
in lime it is I like it and I think that
you're wrong people like people don't
dislike you and you're killing loved
characters I think it's great it's
awesome I think it's a split I think
some people were I think fans in the
comic book we're really kind of looking
forward to it um and I think other
people that aren't aware of the comic
book or this character is much just
still kind of dislike negan a lot which
is okay it's not a cheesy bad guy like
some bad guys are a little cheesy but
it's brutal I mean it's really beautiful
you don't want there to tell you
something all the bad guys in movies and
TV they're not bad I'm just
misunderstood by the public because they
think what they're doing is right that's
right they're not doing something
necessarily malicious I think welcome to
earth
definitely works in negan's case I think
to survive that long in this world it's
like if you look at the heroes of the
show Rick and Daryl Dixon and those guys
they've done some horrible things and
remember they killed 30 saviors while
they slept so I've only killed two of
them right think about it when you bring
it down it's it's not even affair you
were gonna have his kids arm cut off
which I thought was great that was great
yeah I thought that was the most intense
part of that first ever yeah I'm gonna
tell you something I said this did today
on the show I'm going to be beyond
furious if Karl kills Nikken if that's
what happens on this show I need to know
right now yeah I don't know okay yeah
because that's what happens I need to
stop watching now as I'm gonna be
yeah very obsessed damn loves Carl and
II can't picture Carl
immoral that tonight yeah no I know I
admitted so what I was hoping Carl's arm
would get cut off in that episode I'm
paying for Carl to meet his maker yeah
yeah uh look Chandler's a good kid and
and I've had have anything against them
brave boy you know yeah just put the
character I'm ready for him too
oh really meet his maker yeah yeah yeah
yeah Sam likes younger children I turned
that that stay BAM
no you misconstrued am you just says
something you brought to my mind one of
the best songs I've ever heard to end a
movie good and it was Daniel annoy song
mm-hmm meet the maker at the end of
Sling Blade great movie I don't remember
that song though great as Mungo's you
were asleep
no no it's wide awake Godfather I didn't
remember what you mean that's some party
yeah okay really pleasure we're going
nowhere I'm just gonna stay DUI
do you think that negan shows zero
vulnerability on the show right and
that's the strength of him like the
trick is that I think he's just a step
or two ahead of where everyone else is
right he's just really very powerful
yeah he's got the the charisma in the
sense of humor and definitely the
brutality going for him but I think he's
just super smart as well and yeah I
think that's where he would you say
secrets my I just farted
Gary just farted Wow the how the [ __ ]
did I walk into this I don't know Gary
welcome to the show you can eat your
hero if anybody Holly yeah yeah yeah
Gary you should be farting on you and
mid explanation did you okay I got
something for you okay good I hope I'm
right do another gasser
I'm putting the book together called
fuchsia isms all right good yeah take a
word
take your letters or spell the word and
create a definition oh really yeah
yeah we're forest which is a natural
bodily function certainly as women and
children all do writing animals
FA rt7 summer because I mean okay
finishing you're right fa are T stands
for feeling a rectal trench mission Oh
see ya know but don't you know that you
get on an elevator and let a let out a
fart and then ask everybody to play name
that smell and you'll be very popular
it really doesn't justify your behavior
yeah yeah doesn't know it just allowed
gasser you just you know what that goes
Sam they justifies everything you're not
which is a fun yeah I know I got except
that that criticism resumes is fun like
here's what here's the problem Gary I
was wondering help me no you're on your
own
I believe I got your back bad barbara
Gary like I was wondering ISM see if who
was wondering I was wondering if there
was going we were going to see more
vulnerability from negan's character on
the show yeah I think that allowed for
in it you're never gonna know that we're
outta here
he's not gonna tell you that that's just
Unitarian [ __ ] hey Sam Sam wake up
that's like asking a scheffers recipe
for a favorite food he makes cream they
love telling the recipes
yeah there's cookbooks I know the
cookbook don't have the recipes of
sacred invasion here's a gesture system
your taste but area you're right I guess
I know a certain Sandra secret recipe
there you go are you saying he's
vulnerable 'ti are those seven herbs and
spices we really can't talk about it at
all no you know what Colonel Sanders
secret is what he deeps he dips yeah all
of his chickens after they're plucked
yeah in kerosene is that right yeah
there's no idea you two piece of chicken
you'll be running to the bathroom I see
you know what you can do to after eating
can plot a bathroom humor yeah like you
think you can get stick matches just big
huh and like your fart I didn't know
that yeah now you do I didn't know that
next time you come in you've got a trick
for us no idea but this would be his
favor
conversation ever hear about that right
walk about farts all the human parts
he'd be how old is your kid he's seven
okay right
this is his conversation right Stoke
right yeah did you hear Gary fart though
while you were talking I did farting is
a strange way very what's it stand for
FA is feeling a rectal trash pit good
that's 100% right it's a hundred percent
right it's fun to have you been at the
Walking Dead fans hated you like do you
get people that can't separate because
people get loved one but not as many as
I anticipated
well mostly people have been very kind
um but there are people I get some good
hate mail and and people just just
dislike the character and they
definitely don't separate between
reality and fiction but mostly folks
have been really cool and you're on
board for at least through season eight
you said is that right right in into
season eight
yeah so you right there mean I don't
know here we don't know we don't know
well you need a good bad guy there not a
good bad guy it's pointless because just
so what they Dom B's are pretty easy to
kill so you need a good villain zombies
are impossible to kill no they're not my
shadow zone will tell you that oh no you
saw some price accounting books and he
gets some B's on his telephone they
can't be dead no you can kill Tommy shot
a shot yeah the brain time to the head
you know what goes ha ha ha thud that's
a zombie laughing his head off
no I guess that so the thud would be the
flow yes and yeah what was that
Klieman how's that how does the zombie
plan I don't know yeah car crash Gary
Busey yeah what was that
I do want another one though yeah yeah
that's a great thing about dead people
they don't fart
they do actually that's what they do
when they got hold on when they die they
do they've made a lot of gas why we
start talking about farts that just
disappears into the atmosphere Gary yeah
why you still talking about farts why
what why are you still talking about
farts cuz they're not yeah I you're not
talking about anything we've interrupted
me with your flatulence
well you know what you're being
interrupted because people don't want to
hear you kidding everybody here Sam
I appreciate that Gary you're probably
you're probably doing us all a service
to tell you the truth I am I think so
you realize it later when you go home
and babe so the next I was reading that
the next project you're doing with the
Anthony Hopkins yeah that right it was a
movie that we shot a couple years ago
that comes out I think I think in in a
week or something's that you I think
December 16th maybe December 16th Jenni
but my publicist who's fired and she is
like I don't hey what what's the movie
called solace it's myself and Anthony
Hopkins and Colin Farrell and Abbie
Cornish I have to tell you like the two
best bad guys on TV right now
are you on Walking Dead in Anthony
Hopkins on Westworld yeah he is he's
awesome amazing it seemed as a bad guy
though I don't ready either are you
caught up um I'm close to being caught
up he starts to get more and more I
don't feel like now thank the last
episode yeah he does but he is uh he's
such an amazing dude that we hit him
really good friend he is amazing a giver
he's such a giver
when was working with others yeah I was
gonna actually ask Jeffrey about that
cuz he just worked have you worked with
Anthony yeah what'd you do with him we
had a panty raid Edlund yeah like
Spanish Jeffrey have you ever worn
panties got him on right God dog is good
so you worked with him he did a film
what's the film you know who are you in
the film I play a cop and he believe it
or not this movie was written as a
sequel to seven the oh wow so originally
was written as a sequel to that and then
it went through a couple different
transformations but I play a cop who
enlist the help of Anthony Hopkins who
is a psychic mm-hmm
to find a serial killer who and he's
he's so good in it and the serial killer
is Colin Farrell
so it's a little bit of psychic
cat-and-mouse yeah yeah it's it's a it's
a cool little movie I'm excited it's
finally coming out you know it got
caught up in the the relativity [ __ ]
yes
and so in activity yeah it's not yes you
see when you open up there you notice
who plays who plays Einstein in this
thing no a relativity of daniel garland
the movie company that got caught up in
like chapter 12 or something and yeah
they're down so all the movies is what
yeah Shepherd shepherd how many sheep do
you have in the movie 100% right you
know speaking of champagne you live on a
farm right you work I do I was [ __ ]
segue well I'm trying to nice there is I
want you to know still sweating about
the shepherd [ __ ] now I'm good yeah you
got there did you have we involved in a
farm births yes matter of fact I've me
too yeah my change in ropes
okay well oh yeah all right listen let's
ask Jeffery the question well yeah what
kind of farm birth right I'm still here
buddy she's got a no highland cattle do
you know the breed of highland cattle
their Scottish bred Cal they all have
long hair and you there may I do so I
had my first baby Humber Albert born in
the spring oh look that's there they are
right there Wow
yeah silly and they are cool they are
silly looking in there also they look
prehistoric yeah they do they're kind of
happy mammoths I don't know that would
make a great coat for some oh you're
right you're absolutely I learned my
farm calcio what is that Kanekalon
highland cattle
Nilan cattle did you don't burn this job
back there did you help did you help Bob
did you help it keep looking live till
it's in Michael but no man um I didn't
have to help because the mama cow Alice
this is her seventh birth and literally
she just she was standing up in just
boom that's literally like he cheeky
[ __ ] and an hour later this little
baby was up and walking and me and my
kid just sat there watching the whole
thing and and he was talking about farts
the whole time goodbye handsome guy got
again did they say kid not the kid
California cows do fart a lot you know
that that's actually a problem you're
once again you know guy boy what's up
yeah
you know what Co W stands for all right
well c'mon woman I see I see that makes
sense it is actually my gonna make sense
very very good well woman did you get -
I do you get to keep the Lucille prop
i'll definitely i'll definitely before
it's all said and done okay yeah yeah
yeah you got it right is there only one
no we have a couple yeah one I guess the
pain tends to get messy yeah you have in
that first scene you pull that bat back
and it was a piece of skull or skin
hanging yeah that first it was a [ __ ]
brutal yeah good brain matter like yeah
everything always like literally like
like a piece of a wig hanging off it was
like somebody's skull yes you I suggest
you when you walk the streets in New
York or Atlanta carry that bad there's
so many out there right now I can't no I
can't walk outside the door without
somebody having to Lucille yeah no it's
crazy
do you have a flavor you give a favorite
negan line yeah you're doing it wrong I
probably [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] at
this point what is it that's my favorite
line what is it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] negan has a bit of Potter's name
that's not this no it's not Disney negan
is every other word is uh is a the [ __ ]
some version of [ __ ] you know what that
says for F uck ah please tell no I'm
gonna tell you you should put a book out
with these it was I am abuse isn't book
and [ __ ] F UC K stands for fornication
under consent of the king I heard it was
for unlawful carnal knowledge
well that should touch your stupidity
you Jack Nicholson we'll listen the
Walking Dead is on Sundays at 9:00
[ __ ] Dead on AMC and I will tell you
that your character brought me right
back into the show I thought I was done
and you brought me back in and I thank
you very much I'm in sweet they could
break yeah and I love what you're doing
I'm the newest fan of the show yes you
are ank scary Gary Busey is sticking
around Jeffrey we're gonna let you get
back there guys
your regular interview circuit but I
want you to leave here with the
knowledge that we did try to form a
semblance of an interview I think it was
great good yeah okay it was good yet to
move in the whole time you have a legend
cut a gasser on you what's better than
that you should [ __ ] Gary already right
back